but we begin this morning bracing for
Barry the edges of the tropical storm
are lashing the Louisiana coast with
heavy rain roads are flooded tens of
thousands are without power forcing some
evacuations the storms powerful winds
have toppled trees and blown aluminum
siding around in coastal communities
especially in Chauvin Barre is expected
to make landfall later this morning most
likely as a hurricane about 85 miles
southwest of New Orleans in Morgan City
Louisiana right now the storm is about
55 miles southwest of Morgan City with
maximum sustained winds of 65 miles per
hour
lights are flickering in Morgan City as
the rain moves in right now while
forecasters have described berry as
being more of a rain event coming on the
heels of another deluge earlier this
week there are concerns about the strong
winds and dangerous life threatening
storm surge David bego begins our
coverage in Morgan City David good
morning Jeff good morning we lost power
here at the hotel and throughout the
city you have thousands of people that
don't have power what we are feeling
right now are the winds that are really
starting to pick up no rain but again we
are in the bullseye of what's expected
to be those heaviest rain bands that
could drop up to 20 inches of rain now
let me tell you this storm is crawling I
mean it is just inching 5 miles an hour
so they thought the landfall was going
to be at 7 a.m. this morning now
forecasters have backed that up to
around noon Jeff Barrett deli we'll have
more on that shortly as we stand in
Morgan City we're talking about this
area north toward Baton Rouge being the
one that could get some of the heaviest
rainfall and within the last couple of
years Baton Rouge had a devastating
flood and so people there are waking up
this morning watching the news and
worrying about what's headed their way
toward the West is where we're thinking
the eye of the storm could pass the
Acadiana region of south Louisiana where
I am proud to say I grew up on the
eastern side in New Orleans I just
talked to a meteorologist at our
affiliate wwl who said David I have
lowered our rain chance I think we'll
get you know 8 to 10 inches not up to 20
as we thought we may have had but again
the real concern here and forecasters
have said it's not necessarily the way
even though they expect berry to become
a hurricane before landfall it is the
devastating rain but Michelle as I come
on the air this morning we are not
seeing much rain and the reports we we
do have from social media from our crews
that are in the area the flooding is
very minor so far minor storm surge not
much to speak up this morning other than
the high winds that are whipping right
now as we wait for berry but again we're
talking about a midday landfall as it as
it looks right now
the silver lining we hope continues
David thank you